Шановні колеги я попрошу зараз от
спокійно і дуже тихо мене послухати
Шановні колеги будь ласка припиніть
будь-які розмови і просто послухайте
одну хвилину
А можна будь ласка послухати я звертаюся
до народних депутатів ми говоримо зараз
про армію
85-річний сумчанин Микола Іванович
продав квартиру і дачу та віддав гроші
на збройні сили України Я думаю всі з
вас бачили цю новину
натомість сьогодні
парламент хоче забрати гроші у армії і
віддати на дороги не більше не менше і я
вам скажу щоб ми не потім не
звинувачували що я щось видумую я зараз
процитую цей закон
пропонується виключити статтю 38 закону
України про державний бюджет України на
22-й рік згідно з якою у 22-му році як
виняток з положень статті 24-2
бюджетного кодексу України кошти
державного дорожнього фонду
спрямовується першочергово на
забезпечення потреб сектору оборони
Шановні колеги я просто зараз звертаюся
не до тих кому до лампочки армія І хто
Зараз розмовляє і не звертає увагу на
мій виступ а до тих хто волонтерець до
тих хто служив збройні сили де ти хто
сьогодні допомагає збройним силам цей
закон категорично не можна приймати не
тисніть бездумно-зелені кнопки не можна
забирати гроші у армії тому ви знаєте
оце голосування воно буде лакмусовим
папірцем для всіх і для нових депутатів
які сьогодні прийняли присягу
і для тих хто сьогодні каже що він
допомагає фронту але дуже цікавий момент
на кону збройні сили України сектор
безпеки і оборони і дороги Обирайте це
ваш вибір
пропоную голосувати червоними дякую
колеги я закінчувати і прошу підтримати